here are the three big takeaways from
the Supreme Court decision on Obamacare
folks such as Washington Post columnist
George Will are working to say that the
real silver lining is the clear language
the court used in limiting Congress's
use of the Commerce Clause as will wrote
Roberts got the court to embrace
emphatic language rejecting the Commerce
Clause rationale for penalizing the
inactivity of not buying insurance now
well could be right that the decision
may spark a backlash in favor of smaller
government or at least one that calls a
tax attacks and not a mandate but
anybody who thinks the government at any
level will feel even the slightest bit
limited by this ruling is flat-out wrong
let's leave aside the large and
unchanged fact that Obamacare remains
unpopular most recent polls show
majorities of Americans opposed to it
and that number rises among those who
say they are well informed Obamacare is
essentially Romneycare on steroids so
having the architect of the ladder
blasting the former for doing what
Romney crowed about doing in the Bay
State is a tad confused and it doesn't
help that Romney is vowing to repeal and
replace Obamacare immediately upon
taking office the repeal part is
self-explanatory if not fully convincing
but what's he going to replace it with
and if it's not a real market driven
plan that dismantle is not only
Obamacare but Medicare why am i
listening one of the major selling
points of the new law was that it would
bend the cost curve down do obamacare
supporters seriously think that
increasing government involvement in
health care is going to keep costs low
Medicare a single-payer system run by
the federal government is the single
biggest factor in rising entitlement
costs Medicaid is a classic case of
paying more for less that is costs keep
going up while outcomes are truly dismal
for the poor folks trapped in
a recent analysis by the firm Bradley
woods projects that insurance premiums
will rise by about seven and a half
percent annually under the law that's
not only way above inflation it's much
higher than health care costs were
rising before the government created
Obamacare for reason TV I'm Nicolas